Dear kitten, imagine a cat.
Now, take away independence, cleanliness and intelligence.
What you have left is basically a dog.
Here's an example.
Yesterday, I saw the dog sitting on his butt, scooching forward with his front paws.
And he looked over at me.
And you know what he said?
He said, "Check it out."
"I'm walking on two legs, just like the peoples do."
I mean, it gives you an idea on what we're dealing with here.
Dear kitten, the dog is the sort of creature...
...that will decide whether it should put something in its mouth...
...by putting it in its mouth.
That's the level of decision-making that goes on.
They basically eat everything.
Case in point: butt paper.
They even eat those weird, brown, dehydrated, pip nuggets that the humans give us.
Don't get mad.
Let the dog eat all of our dry food.
If it gets caught, it gets put in jail.
And right then, we can enjoy the moist deliciousness of the can without interruption.
It's a gambit.